[Music]
Sam's are noticing that Shakira
resembled someone else on Sunday night
[Applause]
[Music]
I love them
her character from Zootopia
when the directors and the producers of
the movie told me about gazelles
character I felt an immediate
identification with her gazelles
glittery red combo is strikingly similar
to what the singer rocked during the
Superbowl halftime show
even brie Larson took notice but here's
the thing gazelle from the 2016 animated
Disney movie is fully based off Shakira
herself the directors of the movie
really wanted to make gazelle look like
me
personality-wise she is as opinionated
as I am so that's that that was taken
care of but we wanted to make her
physically anatomically look more like
me so I suggested a few things here and
there you know like yeah add a little
more eyelashes and darken the color of
her eyes and make her hair a little wavy
err that's it to them guys she's too fit
she's just Guinea just give her some
meat you know give her some hips and huh
and so they listen to me and they made
her curvier bigger hips the outfit even
resembles what Shakira wore to a New
Year's Eve concert in 2010
if that isn't convincing enough this
Super Bowl halftime look was created by
designer Peter Dundas ET asked if the
look was in fact inspired by her
Zootopia character and to put it simply
he told us it was not me when I was a
little girl in Barranquilla dreaming
really big dreaming about you know
conquering
big stages and becoming a super an
international pop star that was
unthinkable for someone like me living
in Barranquilla and and Here I am you
know my family supported me and and
things happen miraculously but I do
believe that that dreams can
come true and as corny as it sounds well
this was our dream come true
Shakira and Jennifer Lopez teaming up
and absolutely dominating halftime
during a press conference ahead of the
big performance Shakira
echoed what she told us in 2016 but when
I was living about IKEA my hometown as a
little girl no one would have thought
that I would end up performing at the
Super Bowl one day there would be
something hard to believe right and it's
a reality today and now and I just think
that this is a palpable example of how
anything is possible
really and the only thing that matters
is the size of your dreams I think that
we are in the Latinos are going through
a difficult time in the US right now and
I think it's very important for us to
convey a message of unity and also to
show whatever relevant force the Latin
community is in this country
[Music]